all right listen we got a big star on
the line you look horrible
we got big stars in studio too you're
not a guy though but you don't look that
great
[Laughter]
i love it what a way to start oh my god
all right listen we got to say i got a
lot of stuff in the warnos thing
yeah we got a lot done already but i got
danny mcbride on the line you do
yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ] legend hey
danny mcbride how are you sir
oh wait a minute
usually that he's got on five hats
i now do radio with a lot of my friends
so it's it's just a whole bunch of
nonsense
i'm actually a professional comedian my
name is chris stefan i'm not one of his
friends
[Laughter]
how are you danny mcbride uh david
mcbride
me i'm doing great today you're doing
wonderful sitting here talking to you
guys
nice haven't had lunch yet ready to
party what are you gonna eat
yeah what are you gonna eat that's right
i just had a [ __ ] moroccan lentil
soup
how about you ask how about you let him
answer the question sorry about that
song
about yourself a [ __ ] moroccan lentil
soup
a sounds delicious
i'm on this new adult lesbian diet dude
all right it's hearty bro
it's hard oh yeah it's very hearty yeah
what's on what's on
the the menu for that mostly meat a lot
of uh just some like angry a lot of
brittle
all right a lot of brittle i wouldn't
think i wouldn't think meat would be on
a lesbian diet oh they're dark they ate
meat in the dark
really like a roast beef some of them
eat me i got the heart of a lesbian
before he passed
[Laughter]
yeah we usually start off with a lot of
energy so it's kind of the worst time to
take a phone call from a big star
in that way i want to break it down
danny i got to tell you so
everyone told me about vice principal
and i blew it off for whatever reason
because i got kids on a radio show
and then you were supposed to call in
about a week or two ago
so i binge watched it i was like [ __ ] i
got to get this show
done yeah and i loved it yep but i'm a
little oh that's awesome to hear but i'm
a little late to the party but
i'm glad i you know i watched every
single episode
and uh and the season finale wow amazing
you saw i didn't see it but i'm a big
eastbound and down fan
and i loved his character in the movie
about the end of the earth when he just
plays a [ __ ] psycho
i love that he almost stole that movie
he did steal that movie not almost he
did he's the [ __ ] man
well i was being polite because i know a
few of the other guys in that movie
i want to be the brooklyn danny mcbride
yeah yeah my goal
so when we're talking about vice
principal and you said yeah it was
amazing you just you didn't watch it
you're just making believe i was saying
i was just i thought i was talking about
whatever dude y'all ain't [ __ ] bro yeah
right you shut up karate
go get you [ __ ] look
sorry danny i'm sorry about that let's
get a couple minutes with that
asking smells like a misdemeanor
yeah we're all fans
we're all fans of danny mcbride i've
known him forever i love danny mcbride
um when is when is the second season of
vice principals coming around
first of all uh the second season is
done we you know we've got both of those
at once
wow really that way if anyone if people
hated it they would have no choice but
to have to see the rest of it because it
was finished and
didn't change their mind so uh so it
comes out i i think it's gonna be later
this year i don't know if it's this
summer or this fall but yeah it's all
it's all done it's it's ready to be seen
uh
yeah we're excited about it i mean it's
the second season is pretty nuts uh
yeah i mean we're just kind of getting
warmed up with that first one well i
love the first season and it ends with
you on the ground with your car on fire
so obviously you know obviously you're
alive we just gotta i guess i guess the
second season starts with you in the
hospital and then
it's all about trying to figure out what
you'll have to see what happened no
do you guys in outer space
do you guys tap into a lot of that i
know there's a huge market now for like
teachers that are dating students and
stuff does that
hit any of the episodes we stayed away
from it you know
that's an important thing to us you know
we didn't want to trivialize it
yeah and who was your vice principal
growing up danny
never never met him once i don't i can't
remember his name
what's her name i'm [ __ ] my boss what
we had raleigh coleman dude his brother
had the most beautiful afro with the j
curl of what he kind of liked to like
point to me when he said
he's a black dude huh because you kind
of leaned to me when you said it he's
looking for the stuff
[Laughter]
how would you know the name of your vice
principal yeah you're gonna get in
trouble you could know that that's crazy
that's why the show shows it's a good
last name that's a good name though he
has speakers in his trunk too to do with
his dogs my principal name was mr
coleman i
don't know his first name in uh uh
middle school that's what i'm saying
yeah beautiful man beautiful man
beautiful man but anyway back to danny
danny how was it uh acting with walton
goggins my
god is he a great actor he is man he's
nuts man he's awesome i've always liked
him and everything i saw him
and when we made when we wrote this we
uh we didn't want to get somebody who
was just like uh
who you had seen really funny before we
wanted to kind of walton just seems kind
of dangerous yeah
and evil and so he uh yeah he went to
the top of the list
hell yeah you django that [ __ ]
is hilarious
he's great he's the uh he's the uh
obviously the other vice principal as as
these two guys trying to become the
principal of
the high school so uh i guess it's out
on dvd right now that's why you're
you're you're calling uh no i think i
think it's out but i don't even do
people even buy dvds i don't know
god no i do i'll buy it dude
a lot of people are the korean ladies in
the uh in the in the
barber shop on staten island
for a dollar now i haven't seen it yet
is it kind of like uh have you guys seen
lean on me is it like that at all
what it it it is like that if if you
were rooting for the people
against the principal okay right right
exactly yeah that's a good one the smoke
crack don't you
the show has a taste of the show has the
show has a taste of bill murray in the
beginning oh wow little taste he's the
principal and uh
he's he's leaving and then these guys
are trying to become the man
okay and then they uh do a left turn and
they get a principal from philly
a sassy female black lady
she was a beautiful woman that's right
beautiful lady
and then these kids coleman riley
coleman boy thank you
yo danny i thought you were legit in the
heartbreak kid too
that i [ __ ] thought that movie was i
know it's an old school throwback but
that's when i first started [ __ ] with
danny mcbride yeah but i thought you
were great just as an adolescent
in general and just as a young person so
i'm even going way back way deeper
that's an adolescent in general
i think your dick tastes funny that's
awesome well that's crazy but they're
enjoying it
i think it tastes funny yeah puberty
well i think you handled puberty like a
champ
and then the other thing is you're
taking on the halloween um
franchise
mike michael myers yeah what what shit's
real is that weird
[ __ ] your cbs this guy's killing it hell
yeah
only as a writer not as an actor i'm not
gonna play michael myers but uh
but yeah david green the other guy i uh
that he's the guy who directs the second
season of vice principal he's a guy i've
known since college we've done
pineapple express together and your
highness and uh yeah
we have a we have a take and we were
able to pitch john carpenter how we
wanted to kind of
reboot halloween and he was into it so
they're going to give us a shot at it
i would imagine you're just going to
flip that [ __ ] completely on its
on its head right [ __ ] yeah dance you'll
have to see
dude i want to see y'all fight
thanksgiving dude like a fight off
how cool is that though that's awesome
halloween versus thanksgiving yeah there
you go
yeah at the showdown everyone's been
waiting for it
now i'm in no one else has seen vice
principals
i haven't seen it but it's so good it's
on my list
to watch for sure and i was stupid
everyone told me how great the show is
i'm like yeah yeah yeah you never seen
eastbound and down of course i do that's
the [ __ ] i've known danny
forever how about how about i go back to
foot fist way
yeah that was beautiful and that's when
he taught karate too as well and uh
my actually they played they played
eastbound and down at my cousin's
funeral too
um i think they just had it on the
background somebody was watching it
some country
[Laughter]
so it wasn't planned it just happened
somebody was watching it on his phone
there you go danny mcbride they also
watched a family feud
and also we have the same blood type so
if you ever need a donor hit your boy
i'll answer you through the mail dog i
will ounce you through the mail
oh yeah praise god
all yeah
i love danny mcbride dude who doesn't
he's [ __ ] amazing he's incredible
yeah are you on set still danny mcbride
i'm not on set i'm just sitting in my
office and just enjoying this morning
dick sucks this is amazing
[Laughter]
those balls what's your sperm count
danny i'm actually curious about this
because i should have
[Laughter]
bro they said you were on set uh
the other day he said he's not no the
other day when he was supposed to call
in
now i'm just in the office today all
right what does danny mcbride's office
look like yeah
it's like a tgi friday isn't it
[Laughter]
dude you know rabies is coming back do
you know that or not daniel
yeah i've heard i've heard yeah yeah
yeah what what's the one thing in your
office right now
point point at something and tell us
like the best thing in that office
yeah like a gift though come on what is
it somebody said an autograph is it a
picture with you and obama
a souvenir or something what do you got
it's nothing it's a you know what i'm
looking at a a
glass bottle of tequila that's shaped
like a pistol
time to commit suicide yeah that's cool
man
dude what's the best thing you ever made
love on daniel
[Laughter]
because you seem like a real adventurous
dick worker i don't know what you've
been out there
like the best thing you've ever made
love on top of brother
it was a tempur-pedic
money now classic nice
yeah oh my god weird question something
nicer
like out there you know like a like an
automobile or like a will farrow
not not a wheelbarrow
oh yeah nonsense
after he helped him with foot pissed
believe away
that movie came out of nowhere how much
you guys make that for 60 thousand
dollars
yeah it was like 60 grand we made it
then it got into yeah got into sundance
and we had to put a few more bucks on
the credit card to
finish it but uh yeah it was made for
under 100 grand and how long did it take
you to shoot that
sweet daniel oh man like 10 minutes i
think
yeah i think we switched it out for like
two weeks so it was not not much
wow yeah do you still have a lot of the
skills that you learned for that or was
that
everything i've held on to those you
know there were a lot of them were
natural i still have
the karate key it sits in my in my
closet and i'm not sure what to do with
it but it's just there it was too much
to get rid of but
it's there it's gross smells hell yeah
it sounds beautiful
i'll send it over hey it could be your
let's call it your blood donor's outfit
hey did you uh spray a hot pine into a
freaking ziploc bag
right now daniel [ __ ] did you see
uh trump's press conference today i
missed it was it exciting
yeah it was awesome i thought you saw
some of it no but it's all [ __ ]
awesome dude
he's out of his mind it's awesome
anybody can be president now but as soon
as you say he's out of his mind then the
black man didn't convince you of that
it woke me up to the idea
you think trump's out of his mind danny
mcbride
i need to follow i need to pay more
attention to what else is happening in
the world cause i just focus on my own
amen the world's crumbling yeah that's a
small way to go i think
i'm doing great look inward today he
said the press is
out of control they are he said the
press is completely out of control
yeah out of control and now what's up
all the press
everybody and now cnn is not only fake
news now it's officially
very fake news with him that came out
today that's big
that came out today it's a code red dude
i hate the news here's what i use bro
intuition and rumors good rumors
you got the news
[Laughter]
[Music]
well i don't think we got anything done
here but uh what are you talking about
it was wonderful to talk to you guys
know what i'm gonna have for lunch
lentils that's it ask for those moroccan
lentils wait we got that done i got that
he's got a tequila in the shape of uh
john on his desk
yeah he's going to jizz on theo's face
in exchange for a pint of oh plus all
right
yeah same blood type as
as theo i don't know how you know that
but michael landon who's no longer with
us
expresslane huge michael landry you
figure out what celebrities have the
same blood type as you yeah dude they
have a website
oh my gosh i've heard of that yeah gaga
if you ever need me
uh vice principal season one you can get
that now even though most people don't
buy dvds or blu-rays yeah but you could
yeah you buy it on your tv
i buy that on my verizon files player
break the mode apple tv yeah
yeah it's worth it it's worth getting it
getting it and then uh
and then he's doing the halloween
franchise oh man man there you go
coming in night night that's right
eric just told me you're working on the
new alien too there danny mcbride
what did that we shot that last year yes
getting ready to come out i think
in the can wait when is it coming out
comes out i think
may 19th are you excited about that you
must be
oh man i can't wait to see it i mean
it's one of the few movies i've been in
where i just really do
want to see what the hell it all is
going to look like right together most
of the time i
won't i was like i was there i've seen
it i don't need to go see the finished
product with this
i thought i have to go see the finished
product yeah man that's awesome because
they have
the aliens and [ __ ] in post right yeah
there you go they did
they had some on on set which is pretty
crazy like you really do just they they
just grow those aliens for real they
chase you eat people
wow oh wow you get it i know you get it
in this movie i know you do not survive
what uh ridiculous gun did they give you
there for the movie i got to pick my own
gun i picked uh i picked a sawed-off
shotgun i thought nice yeah
that's how you go oh
mcbride have you seen uh family man that
movie
family nicholas cage in it oh i have not
seen that i know
doesn't he go back in time or make
another life or something like that i i
have to
i think i saw when it first come out but
i don't really remember it it's one of
your favorites
yeah you gotta watch them and it's good
dude it is good yeah yeah it's good
that's the movie that makes uh bird
christian cry every time he sees it
beautiful movie burt cries he cried on
air here
it's fake that's not that one no one is
[Laughter]
he could hang up at any point you don't
want to hang up he's having fun theo
it's obvious he's having a good time
we're not wasting his time he's hungry
get those lentil soups
he's got [ __ ] to bring him his soup
yo danny remember the name chris and
stefano i'm coming up with that
halloween son
i'm coming in to be the first and killed
all right
have a good afternoon guys oh yes that's
a sign off all right
what the hell he's ready to go i have
two more questions
he's tired he's tired all right thank
you so much
bye guys he's had with us thank you
danny